[Music]
can you identify yourself with one of
these postures nowadays our lifestyles
are causing us to have really bad
posture from posting habits such as
slouching sitting in front of the
computer for an extended period of time
constantly texting and looking down at
your phone
carrying really heavy bags or ladies
wearing high heels
24/7 when our spine is positioned in an
unnatural alignment the curves are
exaggerated which can be due to tight or
weak muscles resulting in bad posture
and corrected posture over time can lead
to chronic pains a good posture is when
you hold your body upright where the
least strain is placed on the supporting
muscles and ligaments during movement it
is extremely important to have good
posture when you have proper posture it
improves bodily alignment eliminates
back or neck pain improves circulation
digestion breathing makes you look
taller and also makes you look and feel
confident so let's talk about the four
common types of bad postures and how you
can change it lumbar lordosis your lower
back curves inwards more than it would
naturally do there's an imbalance
between the muscles surrounding the
pelvic bone this can be caused by
sitting too much and not stretching
which shortens the hip flexors so what
we're trying to fix is the tight hip
flexor weak core muscles and weak glute
muscles here are the exercises you can
do first hip flexor stretch place the
left knee on the floor
directly under the left hip and the
right foot in front of the right hip in
a 90 degree angle then lean forward into
your right hip and you will feel the
stretch on the left hip flexor hold for
30 to 45 seconds and change side repeat
for a total of three to four rounds next
knee
chest stretch lie flat on your back and
bring both knees close to your chest you
will feel the stretch on your lower back
hamstrings and glutes cat cow stretch
start on all fours in a neutral position
back flat and abs engaged on the exhale
round your spine up towards to the
ceiling tuck your chin towards your
chest releasing the tension from the
neck on the inhale arch your back lift
your head and tailbone up towards the
sky
this helps to release the tension from
the hips and back hip bridge lie with
your back and both feet flat on the
floor slowly draw your abdominals up
toward the ceiling squeezing your glutes
right at the top for five seconds
release back to stuffy position and
repeat this exercise will strengthen the
glute muscles and to release tension
from the lower back another basic
exercise to perform is abdominal
crunches which will help to strengthen
the core muscles lie on your back with
both feet flat on the floor slowly
crunch up by lifting your shoulders off
the floor hold for two seconds
Lowestoft back down and repeat thoracic
kyphosis or hunched back you have
rounded shoulders the joints of your
collarbone and breastbone are unstable
in order to stabilize this joint your
body recruits the pectoris muscles by
bringing the shoulders forward when your
shoulders are constantly pulled forward
the muscles in your back become
lengthened and weak and your chest
muscles are tight this can be caused by
sitting with a bad posture or hunched
over a computer for an extended period
of time
the first exercise is simply to be aware
and correct your posture by drawing both
shoulders down and bringing them back to
open up your chest this is the neutral
position you should be in next exercise
chest open to stretch your chest place
both hands at the back of your head
squeeze your shoulder blades together to
create tension in the upper back and
shoulders while opening up at the chest
hold this position for 10 seconds
release and repeat five times you can
even do this while sitting at a desk
Bert dark start on all fours in a
neutral position keeping your back flat
and pelvis still reach your right arm
forward and left leg back don't let your
hips Rock or your lower back arch to
really prove your apps in hold for five
seconds return to the starting position
and repeat on the opposite side complete
ten reps on each side Superman
start by lying on your belly face down
arms extended forward lift your arms
shoulders and legs few inches off the
floor squeeze your gluts lower back and
bend your elbows to bring your arms back
to squeeze the mid back hold for two
seconds return to starting position and
repeat for at least ten reps
this exercise will strengthen the glutes
and back muscles dart beats again start
by lying on your belly face down arms by
side with the palms facing up engage
your glutes and lower back muscles to
lift your upper body and legs few inches
off the floor exhale and pulse for 10
beats and repeat Cobra start face down
and place your hands close to your chest
elbows pointed back push up to lift your
chest off the ground look up and feel
the stretch on your lower back hold for
ten counts return to the starting
position and repeat for another three
more times forward head your head
position is protruding forward ahead of
your shoulders
if you were to lean against the wall the
back of your head does not touch at the
wall this is very common in people who
sit in front of the computer for most of
the day if left untreated this can cause
tension stiffness or pain in your neck
shoulders and back to make matters worse
it can also lead to migraine
jaw pain and arthritis in the cervical
spine so what we're trying to fix is the
weak front neck muscles and the short
side and strained back neck muscles
the exercises you can do are chin tucks
simply draw your chin in towards your
neck hold that position for 10 seconds
release and repeat next head stretch
use your hands to gently stretch your
neck up down and sideways hold each
position for at least 5 seconds repeat 3
to 4 rounds and this will help to
release the tension on the neck head
with shoulder rotation in a neutral
position place both arms by the side of
your head gently rotate the neck and
show this to one side and feel the
slight squeeze on your upper back and
show this release to the center and
repeat on the other side and the final
workout is to show the blade squeeze
move your shoulders forward up and back
in a circular motion and squeeze your
shoulder blades for two seconds complete
10 reps this exercise will help to
strengthen the upper back muscles to
support your neck sway back you have a
slight rounding of the shoulders an
extended neck and a flattened lower back
your pelvis and hips are pushed in front
of the line of your shoulders so what
we're trying to fix and strengthen are
the weak abdominal muscles weak hip
flexors tight hamstrings and back
muscles and the shot and tight chest
muscles the exercises to do our
hamstring stretch lie down on the floor
face up with the knees bent and feet
flat straighten one leg and gently pull
your leg towards you while keeping both
hips on the floor hold the back of your
leg or your calf hold the stretch for at
least 10 seconds release and repeat on
the other side for a deeper hamstring
stretch use a towel next chest stretch
stand tall extend both arms out to your
side with your thumbs facing up
draw your shoulda blades together to
squeeze the upper back muscles and at
the same time you will feel the deep
stretch on your chest muscles hold for
at least 10
release and repeat hip bridge lie with
your back and both feet flat on the
floor
slowly draw your abdominal muscles up
towards the ceiling squeezing your
glutes right at the top for five seconds
release back to the starting position
and repeat this exercise will strengthen
the glute muscles and to release tension
from the lower back plank keep your
elbows bent at 90 degrees directly
beneath your shoulders and get your core
muscles to keep your body in a straight
line from your head to your feet hold
this position as long as you can
planking helps to develop strength in
the core shoulders arms and gluts which
will have to improve your posture and
the final workout you should all do is
Charles post start in a kneeling
position push your butt back to lower
your body into a child's pose with your
arms stretched forward draw your chest
as close to the floor as possible
to really stretch the entire back out
all these exercises might feel or seem
strange to begin with but perform them
on a daily basis and over time you will
notice that your posture was started to
improve what are the bad postures or
habits can you identify yourself with
let me know in the comments below like
this video and share this knowledge
subscribe to my youtube channel for more
workout videos and fitness tips turn on
your notification button to get notified
every time I upload a new video all the
best